please lately I got a Koran she's gonna
be reading the Koran guys just don't
hold your breath on that but Islam says
that you can't just kill people you're
not allowed to they use the media to
drum up this hatred a Muslim so that we
would beg for our own enslavement so
many good-hearted Muslims that are
withstanding evil and Islam doesn't have
the rage in it that you're told it does
one of the reasons I even started
looking at mozzies is because of how
much Ben Shapiro hates them
anyone Ben Shapiro hates that much there
has to be something there that's good I
probably should read the Quran and
Muhammad peace be upon him
salam-o-alaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the Deen show I'm Eddie your
host and we have from the Muslim skeptic
Daniel hey Kiki how did I do
how [ __ ] how are you good good to have
you with us here yeah my pleasure
great to be here how you been good I'm
going you know are you doing some
someone from greco-roman wrestling some
good upper body takedowns yeah to some
jujitsu courtesy of how's that making
some good memories and houses you too
huh great very invigorating got my blood
flowing pump yeah do some good push-ups
here I see yeah yeah you got a good rope
you got a good strong grip you know more
great you don't want Daniel grabbing
yeah they can see the grip here here now
let's doing some grip fighting yeah yeah
so we're Tama this is so so important
now so tell us before that so you're
from the Muslim skeptic this is where
you tell us a little about about yours
oh I didn't yeah so Muslim skeptic calm
is my website and I dedicate the website
to addressing common doubts in Islam
trying to strengthen the faith of
Muslims by addressing the Shu bohat
these doubts in Islam and so my
background is in philosophy I studied
philosophy and physics at Harvard
University and hamdullah you know as I
grew in my knowledge of Islam I realized
that there are certain issues and
questions that Muslims have and that I
had about Islam in the modern world and
it seems like Islam clash
with a lot of modern values and I want
to understand like okay is Islam right
or is modern values coming from
liberalism feminism secularism
materialism atheism what's right here
right because well it's either Islam or
the other and so I want to do that kind
of analysis and use my education to
address these issues and show to myself
and to others that Islam is the truth
Islam is the pinnacle of rationality and
morality and all of these different
aspects of life and so a lot of the
doubts that some Muslims have is because
you have a system that's saying no the
best that the world has to offer is
coming from atheism is coming from
science is coming from secularism is
coming from liberalism and Islam is just
backward stuff from the seventh century
that's not relevant that's not
applicable the Quran is full of wrong
ideas all of these doubts that some
Muslims get influenced by and you know
lose their faith by and so I felt the
need to address these things and that's
why I studied philosophy SAT physics and
then I want to use that for helping the
community helping Muslims with these
doubts so Muslim skeptic calm is where I
I do a lot of writing and videos and
then I started an Institute as well
called Alesana Institute and we can talk
about that but it's dedicated to courses
addressing major issues like why do
women have to wear hijab and not men why
is it that in Islam there are certain
gender roles what about equality
what about polygamy what about certain
things when it comes to Islamic law
Islamic law seems very barbaric to a lot
of people in the world say including
Muslims some Muslims unfortunately so
how do we show that no Islamic law the
Sharia is not barbaric in fact it is
guidance it is the pinnacle of
rationality and morality that all of
humanity can look to for guidance on how
to live and how to organize and how to
be in this world in this dunya so this
is just a sample of like what I talked
about so it's very interesting from
someone an academic who actually you
graduated from the
Harvard University yeah I'm going to
nity to study there for my undergraduate
degree and I guess I say eight physics
because at one point I thought that what
how am I going to understand the world
around me how am I gonna stand in myself
what are the source of some of these
answers and what the modern world says
is that science is the answer science
can tell you answer and answer all these
questions and so that this is the kind
of delusion that I was suffering from as
a youth in high school and so I want to
study physics and then when I got into
physics at Harvard and you have
professors who have won the Nobel Prize
and are considered the top in their
field and you ask them certain basic
questions and they don't know the answer
you know they can talk about these
equations they can talk about you know
the motion of matter and energy and all
of this but then you ask them a deeper
question like okay well where is this
matter from where is this energy from
how can you explain this and that and
then there will be no answer and they'll
be confused and they'll kind of brush
you off like stop bothering me with this
so that was a wake up call okay this is
a very limited way to know is physics
and science and so that led me to go to
philosophy but philosophy also has these
kinds of problems it's all human thought
human mentality and the human mind is
limited human beings need guidance right
and this is something that Muslims
hamdullah if we've been blessed to be
Muslim and we've been blessed to learn
this lesson there's no more important
lesson that guidance is from Allah alone
our Creator we cannot know about you
know where we're going where we're from
what is it what is life all about what's
our purpose the human mind can't just
figure that out and that's why when you
look at a field like philosophy the best
you know quote-unquote best minds the
secular minds they don't have answers
they have been they've been debating the
same questions since the ancient Greeks
over three thousand years still debate
still debating these issues so it's just
fun it's just speculation as Allah says
enough
all they do is speculate right without
knowledge okay they have maybe a little
bit of knowledge Allah has granted them
and they are so confused because they
just speculate and when you say Allah
you're simply when you're talking
referring to the Creator it's not like
the creator of the Muslim is the Creator
who created the whole universe and
everything in it the same God that Jesus
Abraham Moses all these messengers that
came out of their law sent them out of
love Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him being the last the final
messenger they all brought this guidance
that you're talking about this is a
universal way of life for everybody so
nobody's excluded of course and then
when you look at Islam and you really
look at the wisdom the hikmah of Islam
in depth than these this the superiority
of it as a way of life reveals itself
even in LA by God's guidance and then
you can it's like light night and day
right when you compare what Islam offers
in terms of guidance how should you be
married right what is the correct
relationship between a man and a woman
what is the correct relationship between
a father and his son a father and his
daughter right what's the correct
relationship between a community a
member of communities these are major
questions that form the fabric of our
lives but where is the guidance can you
open a book you go to library and open a
secular book an atheist book that will
give you guidance on these issues how to
live your life how to even forget about
relations with other people how about
internally right how would you know
something like jealousy Hassad okay how
would you know that that's something bad
that that's something that will destroy
you okay you have certain secular
philosophers that will maybe touch on
this briefly but the deep insights about
something like hasit or hatred or envy
or backbiting
Pepa everything is laid out oh you're
not gonna find this in secular
philosophy this is all open the Quran
open the son of the products my son
peace be upon him these are the things
that guidance for life even in for your
own self your own heart yeah you're not
gonna find anywhere yeah
so before people were washing their
hands before surgery our mcdonald's we
we had that lay down islam we got people
and not to offend nobody but just the
reality when you talk about this has me
think you know from the minut small
things of young people in in in in the
white house who probably don't wash
their reran you know to me you know what
i would say so you from the smallest
things on how to purify yourself out to
be clean like from washing yourself
after you go to the toilet to how to
worship the creator that has an earth
that victory over polytheism the victory
as i had one of my guests he said this
so eloquently islam is the victory of
monotheism over polytheism so how to
worship your creator from the mind new
things to the major things and
everything in between what you mentioned
everything in between is there i wanted
to i go ahead and get you heard of Joe
Rogan yep you've heard a louder Crowder
yes we've we've addressed some of and
our door is always open to Joe and
louder Crowder and many of these other
people who are out there who been
misinformed some maybe have some good
intention to do it they might be talking
on some some some good issues here and
there but when it comes to Islam they've
made some major blunders some of them
have brought on many guests who who are
full of you know it is overtly lying and
spreading false information about
Muslims in Islam there's actually a
writer for the louder Crowder this guy
that we're gonna talk about like you for
us to analyze this kind of react to it
his name is Owen Benjamin he was an
actor comedian he was on that he's been
on a Joe Rogan show he's a friend of Joe
Rogan I know they're still friends he
was a script writer for the louder crowd
a guy and he's pretty well-known
and this is the individual who was again
on that same bandwagon a bashing Islam
but he has some interesting things to
say now about Islam Muslim so I thought
it'd be interesting for us to kind of
take a look you've heard of him I've
heard of Benjamin but I don't know what
he says about Islam so I understood okay
so we'll start from there and we'll go
ahead and and hopefully send a good
positive message to him and many of his
followers who also kind of probably been
victims of the
Shiina yeah yeah oh so adamant about not
hating Muslims because the hatred of
Muslims allowed us to get to beg for our
own enslavement it's like what we need
we need the Patriot address we can't
find the bad terrorists you think
Muslims just hate ariana grande and the
Boston Marathon
they used the media to drum up this
hatred of Muslim so that we would beg
for our own enslavement you know what do
you think of the first thing he said
some some points about our enslavement
you know of making an enemy right and
then we end up enslaving ourselves
because of this fake enemy right I think
that's a good analysis you create a
boogeyman to drum up fear and then
people are more willing to accept your
program right so I mentions the Patriot
Act when he mentions I mean there are so
many things that you can just look at
with that alone but I mean we've lived
through 9/11 I was you know in high
school when that happened and that was
something that completely changed the
course of American history in terms of
domestic policy because you had all of
these new laws surveillance okay the
idea that every single phone call that
you make every single text message email
every communication is now being
monitored that has a really stifling
effect so why would the public agree to
that
violation of privacy the only way that
they accept it is because oh well
there's a bigger threat if you don't
accept this you're going there's gonna
be another 9/11 there's gonna be all
kinds of chaos so you need you have to
accept all our restrictions all of this
grabbing of power by the President
George Bush later Barack Obama and you
accept it because you're afraid for your
life so you're blackmailing people
you're holding the public hostage it's a
great point great point yeah so when you
really when you look at when you when
someone is open-minded enough and they
look at the facts on the ground the
reality you've had it reminds me of
professor Robert Pape from the
University of Chicago and other
academics like ham Tareq's experts and
they just blow this this
myth out of the sky you know that Islam
is some kind of threat and people are
based off Islam they're doing these
terrorist ask Acts he mentions that
Islam had nothing to do it this is
geopolitical this is nothing to do with
the religion of Islam when you have
these are non-muslims saying that if
Muslims have been in the modern world
we've had all of these Muslim countries
what did suddenly a switch go off in
2001 that now they want to you know
destroy America and destroy the West
just because of hatred
you know hating are their freedoms makes
no sense like what what about all of
these generations decades of modernity
right the modern world where you have
these nation-states these Muslim
countries have been broken up basically
dividing and conquering the Ummah and so
only now suddenly there's this
existential threat because of terrorism
from people hiding in caves it doesn't
make sense and I think as time goes on
more and more people are going to see
how ridiculous it sounds and hopefully
you know in history books will show that
the public was manipulated and people
were driven to make completely
irrational decisions for themselves and
for others in their treatment of Muslims
and their consideration of Islam because
of these stories right in Arabic sauce
right these are just stories so it's
unfortunate but hamdullah I'm glad that
people like this Owen Benjamin is
speaking openly about it yeah so if so a
few of the elite can go ahead and profit
off of these Wars make money and feed
the war machine and then divide the
people like what's been happening him it
seems like he's waking he's woken up to
this right right yeah well let's
continue on so he's lately I got a Koran
he's gonna be reading the Koran guys
just don't hold your breath on that I
have so much to learn about the Bible
that my main thing is to help people not
hate so many good-hearted Muslims that
are withstanding evil and they are the
type of people you you want to root for
these scholarly beautiful Muslim people
don't let the media pay
you know 1/5 of the planet is people
that deserve to be bombed as a sacrifice
now my pursuit of the Koran is very
minimal
I'm just being completely I don't hold
your breath on it now he said that twice
is it looks like someone sent him a
Quran I think that's aji International
yeah I would agree that's a good one to
start with huh yeah it's a good
translation good translation why would
you if you look at the Quran is a
potential we know based on proof and
evidence and this is why you actually
you didn't come into Islam blindly I
didn't I wanted to myself I put all the
religions on the table you know
sincerely earnestly was searching for
the truth and Islam provided all the
rational logical evidences with a
believable message that it was indeed
from the Creator that I was there
without a doubt and I believe that
anyone who's sincere and genuine if
they're seeking to know the truth and
they're asking their Creator alone
without any intermediaries right now
putting a God next to God not praying
through Muhammad or Jesus but praying
directly to the creator of the heavens
and earth God Almighty will guide him
from your story I think you've done the
same thing right you were searching for
the truth you your background my
background my parents were also from
from Bosnia Muslim but they weren't
practicing I so I didn't want to just
follow what my parents were upon even
though they weren't practicing I wanted
to make sure that this was tight this
was what it was you know this is the
truth so it seems like why are you
limiting when I hear him say he says
don't hold your breath why not if there
if we're telling this is a look at it as
a potential book from God right if
someone has something addressed to you
from saying it's from a relative of your
mother so you'd read that you'd read the
thing right but this is addressed to all
of mankind this book the Quran
my question is why why would you why
would you limit yourself why won't you
pick it up and read it
some people know right they can just
feel that if I get into it if I get into
this it's going to change my life
and I'm not ready for that change right
and if he didn't have respect if he
thought that oh this is just another
book yeah I'll read it like this
interesting you know just for my you
know entertainment I'll just read
another book I read all kinds of books
but he I can someone who goes out of his
way to say you know don't hold your
breath I'm not
crack this I'm not gonna pay any
attention it's like he's afraid of
something hmm and yeah now you study
psychology I mean you can you can kind
of tell on these human patterns into
somebody I mean this very basic human
pattern you don't even have to study
psychology yeah he knows that okay this
is something weighty this is something
heavy and if I'm going to start reading
it and commit to reading I'm going to
have to come to certain hard
realizations about Who I am and some
people are just not ready to take that
important step that we all should take
yeah of knowing the truth and committing
ourselves to the truth and letting the
truth affect who we are
yeah this is a test of your sincerity
now right if you really love your
Creator the God Almighty Allah if you
really love the one who created you this
is a test now you're being tested right
if your sincerity what else would you
say absolutely no no how can you how can
you what excuses can you give yeah if
she wrote you that letter you'd be
reading it okay let's go on I'm a
Christian I have lifetimes to learn
about the Bible before I can um I can
dive into that let me let me address
that see that's another thing people
many people have they say because we've
had experiences people say well okay I
there's so much more that I have to
learn about Islam before I accept it he
talked about there's so much more that I
have to learn about Christianity before
I can come to to reading the Quran and
you spend a lifetime doing that before I
mean if you look at what Islam really is
it's it's articles of faith the pillars
of Islam the main message of Islam
compared to the main message of
Christianity right there from there you
should be able to make a decision and
the rest of the time you're going to
spend learning all this finer details
and everything else that involves right
that's exactly what you said it's
sincerity and not making excuses
illegitimate excuses so if you want to
make excuses for denying the truth
there's an endless number of things that
you can say but if you're sincere then
you look at something and it's clear
night and day and Christians are in a
very good position as advocates a people
of the book because their bible does
speak about the messenger does speak
about the coming of the Prophet peace be
upon him the Bible the Bible yes and
this is some
thing that other Muslim scholars have
talked about and written about in depth
so it's something that is in their book
so okay if you want to focus on the
Bible then how about these passages how
about these parts of the Bible that are
speaking about a prophet who is going to
come after Jesus peace be upon him a
prophet who's going to come and with an
Ummah okay these are the things that you
can read in the Bible and they've been
suppressed and they've been glossed over
and ignored so okay go that route and
it'll lead back to Islam they were
that's that's profound if they do that
that's that don't limit yourself you
know do the homework but I think that if
anybody goes and searches what you just
said that's a whole nother topic of
itself like Muhammad peace of Moses
being upon at Muhammad in the Bible
right you could write that's a book
that's a whole book by itself right look
at it objectively look at it and see you
you know don't nobody else think for you
just look at it
let's go continue on yes there's a lot
of beauty there and in those people's
hearts some of the most evil people on
the planet are call themselves Muslim
but they're Muslim in name only
because mozzies aren't allowed to kill
you it's it's a sin it's a sin to kill
you and there's like all these like
there is some ways to get around it if
they're in a holy war and bla bla to
things uh and again we're setting he'll
probably God willing he'll get a chance
I'm pretty sure inshallah we say that
he'll watch this inshallah we want him
to feel this good energy coming from us
we wanna want to send him a good message
and we commend him for because you've
heard how we spoke before the kind of uh
you know some days he's a I've watched
some of his stuff recently and he is
definitely brave and talk talking about
certain things he's been demonetized
from YouTube and from YouTube getting so
much money a month and he was willing to
be d monetized by YouTube because he was
talking about certain subjects and some
politically incorrect subjects and so
he's definitely has that kind of bravery
for the truth and not worrying about the
blame of the blamers right yeah so
hopefully that sincerity will lead him
and Allah will guide him to the truth
and all of the things that I hear from
conservative Christians like him many of
those values are within Islam yes for
the pure unadulterated version of them
are in Islam and much more than any
person with a sound heart whether in
America whether in Russia whether any
part of the world can accept because of
that core truth and value within Islam
have you ever heard this term mozzie
masih who he's referring to Muslims as
Muslim yeah started the rocket or II
know I don't know whatever I think he's
trying to be cute or something like
that's fine okay all right and then the
is it's not like derogatory yeah so then
the other one so the proper is a Muslim
and Muslim for Owen if you didn't know
is simply one like Jesus like Moses
Abraham one who has chosen freely to
submit to the Creator to have his inner
and this how you get peace by connecting
with your Lord the one who created you
that's what a Muslim is now he turned he
threw around as a big misconception he
said the holy war there's no such thing
in Islam as holy war is there you heard
you hear this term they try to put jihad
equals holy war what you got to say
about that this is a misconception okay
because holy war is not the correct
translation of jihad but jihad is
something Islam is not a pacifist
religion okay and how can pacifism be
true because even in the most minimal
case ok people understand that you
require defense ok and sometimes you
require offense ok and this is something
that everyone accepts ok anyone who is
living in a country like look at the
United States of America
how much praise is given to the military
you know support our troops defend our
troops these people are sacrificing
their lives for the interests and the
benefit of the nation right and so when
it comes to the military there's always
the offensive and the defensive
capacities right ok so if you accept the
idea
of dying for your country why can't you
accept the idea of dying for your Lord
for your Creator and that's what jihad
is and Christians of all people need to
recognize the importance and the beauty
of this if you believe in a doctrine
that God this is what they claim that
God can sacrifice himself and his body
for the sake of humanity okay so this
idea of sacrificing your body is a it's
a core part of your theology okay so how
can you have a problem with Jihad
sacrificing your body for the sake of
God for a higher purpose for the purpose
of spreading the truth the highest
purpose that anyone can have and so a
Christian should have no problem with
the concept of jihad Americans anyone
who's living in a nation state where
they have the concept of the military
and how many Americans supported the
illegal and unjust war an invasion of
Iraq right and Afghanistan they've
supported that on the basis that is
justified because we are spreading
freedom and democracy and justice right
that was offensive okay Afghanistan as
was proven had nothing to do with any
attack on the United States right Iraq
didn't have anything to do with 9/11 but
they were attacked offensively okay and
I guess I was illegal invasion but
Americans supported that on the basis of
this principle spreading goodness right
and that's what Muslims believe in is
what we spread goodness okay and in
certain contexts and certain situations
today we're not in a position for
anything like that because there's no
you know unified OMA there's no Khalifa
there's no Caliphate there's no
organized political Muslim body to be
engaged in Jihad and in this way but if
we look at the past if we look at the
Prophet peace be upon him like I'm not
an apologist right if you look at the
history of the Prophet peace be upon him
and his companions Islam did
bred through military excursions but
it's wrong to say that Islam spread by
the sword because that's not literally
true
no one Muslims are not allowed to go to
Christians or Jews and hold a sword to
their neck and say or a gun to their
head convert otherwise I'll kill you
that is completely contrary to Islam and
all scholars are agreed on this but the
history shows that the Prophet peace be
upon him and after the Prophet peace be
upon him you had great companions who
were spreading Islam to like Persia so
my parents are Persian I'm Persian
and Islam was spread to Iran to Persia
because of Khalid ib'n Willie the great
Sahabi and I name my own son after
Halima Willie because of my love for
this hobby this companion of the Prophet
peace be upon him and Islam was spread
militarily in the sense that that Empire
was conquered okay but it's what is the
intention here is to spread truth it is
to spread justice it is to spread
goodness right and that's something that
people accept everyone accepts that
there's only a difference between okay
well what is goodness what is truth and
then we can have a conversation about
that and we'll be happy to show that
Islam is the truth and we can have that
conversation yeah so you have that
cleared up there that jihad does not
equal holy war I believe that this is
actually a Christian term holy war this
is not the Crusades the Crusades that's
number one so jihad to struggle and
strive then you have also what you had
talked about in this aspect where you
had for instance if you study history
you had Spain for instance you had two
fractions of Christians fighting each
other and one is oppressing the other
and then you have these Christians who
are opening the doors calling the
Muslims to come in to help could we you
can use this as one example right of a
jihad so then they came in but they
didn't come in now massacring everyone
like like you had Kim what would the
Spanish Inquisition is where they were
just just everybody by the sword convert
or die you had once they were in you had
Islam because of his men I mean
they came in they were some fighting but
at the end you know people were being
oppressed
now Islam comes in just as a slab
established and you can't have peace
without the justice and now people were
freely accepting the Muslims do we it's
hard to imagine because there are so
many connotations and stereotypes yeah
about what does it mean to have like a
conquest yeah right but and though you
say an opening where they opened up they
open and it's basically new management
nothing it's new management but it
doesn't mean you know we're going to go
door to door like this is Nazi Germany
yeah and then we're going to put you in
camps like that people in the prior to
the nation-state and the modern period
you have nation-states but prior to that
you had governorships yeah and people
were used to these changes in management
right it's just a difference of who
you're paying your taxes to and then
there are certain restrictions that will
apply depending on who's in charge but
that was something that was normal and
accepted but the thing is that when you
have the opening of Egypt or you have
the opening of Persia or North Africa or
Spain it wasn't this bloody massacre
it's from the true perspective the
spreading of truth and then within those
lands the people would convert after
seeing the benefits that Islam is
bringing to their land okay we've just
been conquered this is what happened in
Persia okay we've just been conquered by
these Arabs and we have a natural
aversion because of racism to Arabs this
is the Persian Empire but then after a
generation or two we see Wow Aslam is is
has prohibited fornication Islam has
prohibited adultery Islam has prohibited
incest which was a big practise with the
Zoroastrians prior to Islam Islam is
bringing peace Islam is bringing family
cohesion Islam is bringing a strong
community that is oriented toward God
towards loving and
worshiping God we're experiencing all of
these benefits in terms of our material
in terms of our character in terms of
justice Islam comes and prohibits Ussuri
interest right something that is such an
evil social evil that oppresses Islam is
coming and abolishing it you know the
Quran is abolishing it so then this wow
this is the truth like this compared
what we have now under new management
with what we had before ok then this is
how being taught that entire region
became Muslim and some of the greatest
scholars of Islam so in the Islam were
coming from Iran from Persia and so
that's something that I can share part
of my heritage but this happened all
across the Middle East North Africa and
there's nothing that as Muslims we
should be ashamed of that in fact we
have to be proud of that history and
that heritage yeah moving on to the next
but just reiterating this point like
that many people those that know but for
those that don't know you had those
clear guidelines even when the opening
offensive or whatever battles were
taking place before the Geneva
Convention you had the example of the
Prophet SAW some who was sent as a mercy
to mankind where there was a clear if
you're going to engage in battlefield in
battle the restrictions again killing
innocent women children monks in their
places of worship or harming people who
are who are not engaged in the battles
these kind of things this was unknown at
that time I mean there was because
people think like Mongols coming in
everybody's dying pregnant women every
brave and all that this is something an
antithesis of Islam to see those rules
of engagements so clearly laid out even
before the Geneva Convention right it's
something that is contrary to Islamic
principles as you mentioned to just go
and Massacre it's also contrary to the
ID philosophy of Islam at a very deep
level let me explain why because so many
of the conflicts in history the vast
majority are on the basis of ethnic
conflict right you had the Mongols who
invaded
they were an ethnicity and they were
massacring uh you know non Mongols right
you have Han Chinese you have different
African tribes all of this ethnic
conflict in Europe the history of all of
the wars many of the wars were all based
on the basis of ethnicity more than
religion but Islam is not an ethnicity
Islam is a Deen right it's a religion
and people can convert to their religion
and so actually from a material point of
view even if you take out a conception
of God and religion out of it even from
a purely materialistic standpoint it
would be a contrary to the logic of
Muslims to kill non-muslims why because
you want them to convert eventually and
then they're part of your army they're
part of your empire and so your empire
is growing right and you'reyou're
getting that kind of growth in numbers
which is so important in pre-modern
times because whoever has the biggest
army is going to win right it's now in
the battle and and mostly it's a numbers
game so you want as many people as
possible to become Muslim it doesn't
matter if you're black white whatever
race right whatever ethnicity you're
coming in so it's contrary to the flock
but if you have an ethnic based
philosophy that we have a certain race
white black Asian whatever then no we
have to kill the non-whites because they
might start reproducing and then there
are armies that if we like beat them
once and we don't Massacre them all then
they're going to start having kids
they're gonna have babies then their
armies grow your ethnicity is gonna grow
and then they're gonna take their
revenge yeah so from an ethnic basis we
know we have to Massacre as many as we
can yeah and this is what you so we have
to rape as many as we can this is what
you've seen in the in the greatest
genocide after World War Two in Bosnia
where my family's from this is what was
happening nationalistic wars things like
this yeah this is the Serbs yeah yes all
right let's continue on and that's been
exploited by some pretty monstrous
people but it doesn't have the same
language as the Talmud as far as like
just the embracing of the wickedness
human beings can
take anything and make it wicked it's
the terms and conditions you know and
Islam doesn't have the rage in it that
you're told it does and if you think it
does you will be potentially tricked
again into another endless war with
people you've never known ask a Muslim
do you want to hurt me if not cooperate
with each other
verify then trust yeah there's a ton of
Muslims that want to chop your head off
there's a tough bunch of Muslims that
think you are the embodiment of Satan
I'm not speaking for all Muslims but
Islam says that you can't just kill
people you're not allowed to and they've
taken a lot of [ __ ] from the Jewish
media man the Jews hate them one of the
reasons I even started looking at
mozzies is because of how much Ben
Shapiro hates them
anyone Ben Shapiro hates that much there
has to be something there that's good
so I'm wondering where he's getting this
information but I guess he explained it
because I was wondering where is he
getting this interest in Muslims from
and then he said it's like hey Ben
Shapiro
I hate someone so much so much Allah you
know guidance comes from many different
directions so it's something to
definitely reflect on why do certain
people and certain groups that he's
mentioning hate Muslims so much and he
mentioned the Talmud and I think I
haven't listened to him
but I mean if you look at what the
Talmud which is one of the holy books of
Jews and their philosophy about life
it's very different and it just kind of
offends actually the you know anyone who
with a sound fifth row what is said in
the Talmud I'll give you an example on
the Sabbath is allowed for a Jew to help
a non Jew when it comes if a non Jew is
for example injured or sick can the Jew
on the Sabbath call the ambulance to
come and pick him up and take him to the
hospital
so secular Jews will have no problem of
course someone is dying it's a non
but we have to help others out Muslim
will say the same thing there's nothing
in Islam that prevents Muslims from
helping non-muslims in that kind of
situation but the Orthodox and the
ultra-orthodox Jews going based on their
books on the such as the Talmud this is
violating the Sabbath to help a non Jew
in that time of need if it's on the
Sabbath so things like this I'm sure
Owen Benjamin and others have read into
and studied Judaism we have to get out
of this mindset that all religions are
the same and and all religions are much
you know Judaism is monotheistic because
that's actually not true Judaism is not
a monotheistic faith and if you actually
look at the books of Jewish theology
this becomes clear there's an emphasis
on orthopraxy practice ritual and then
ask a Jewish person Orthodox Jew well
what happens after we die is there a
heaven is there hell is there something
that somewhere that people go after they
die and they'll say well we don't know
we don't know and when we don't
speculate about that so their theology
actually is open to Kabbalah for example
where you have worship of other deities
sacrificing to other deities and there
and and so you find this kind of stuff
in medieval Judaism and more modern
Judaism as well and that's why Jews the
majority don't practice Judaism are not
Orthodox because they've been repelled
by their own religion because of these
kinds of aspects so I'm not trying to
like characterize all Jews as the same
but if we look at the core of the
religion and actually look at the books
then that's when the the true essence of
the religion comes out and you'll find
that it's not monotheistic it has this
kind of extreme prejudice that you know
others can tell like oh this is a way
too far like someone has died
you're not gonna call the ambulance
because it's against the Sabbath and
it's a non Jew so this is the signed of
things that you find and it repulses
people now many people that's one one
misconception people have is that islam
teaches us to hate jews but if we we
look at the history if muslims hated
jews then you would you wouldn't have so
many jews who sought refuge in Albania
Bosnia in Muslim lands when Christians
the Crusaders were killing them because
they killed their Lord you know Jesus
Christ right so there's a professor
historian academic he wrote a great
essays called how Islam dr. David
Morenstein I believe his name is he said
the title is Islam saved the jury how
Islam saved the jury the Jewish people
right so like I said most Jews are not
following Orthodox Judaism most Jews
don't know what's in the Talmud the
Talmud says that Jesus Christ peace be
upon him is in hell boiling in a vat of
excrement this is in the Talmud yes
and so this is what they believe about
Jesus Christ the Messiah now can you say
that because they have the wrong
understanding of the Messiah the term
they have the Christian understanding
that when they turn when they when you
say Jesus now they think of the
Christian version of Jesus they don't
know they are referring to the person
the person yeah they were referring to
the person not talking about the idol
yeah that Christians have created and
the Trinity they're talking about the
person the person the person of Jesus
yes yes but most of them have the the
view of Jesus the Christian view of
Jesus the majority but then Allah so
Allah talks about in the Quran that they
know the messenger like they know his
their own child right yeah so they
rejected they knew that he was the
Messiah and they rejected him just like
they knew that the Prophet Muhammad
peace upon him was the final messenger
and they rejected yeah okay so this is
you know very bad stuff and again it's
just Orthodox Jews that will even know
about these details the majority of Jews
are secular and they're not practicing
their faith and even even in the poor so
that's what I'm thinking more the second
the ones who are not practicing this is
with the the the the modern day view
they have about about Jesus would come
from the Christian view but the people
who study who studied these texts deeper
they they know there have been more
exposed to the Muslim the proper view of
Jesus being a messenger and not being a
literal son of God or God you get you
see you know the difference between Jews
ya know where you have the Christians
they don't believe because the Jews are
waiting for a messiah to come right the
Christians take Jesus as the God and
raise him up to a status of three in a
Trinity Muslims we accept him as the
Messiah who came but not but as a mighty
messenger like Abraham Moses and all the
other message but not as a god or a
little son of God right now so I mean
when it comes to what you're saying
before that Muslims are not supposed to
kill or harm ya because they're
protected people even obviously in in
our times in this situation with theirs
in the West Muslims don't have any
authority to Muslims don't have any
authority over any group but even in the
past and the time of the probably peace
be upon him and the caliphs Jews were
protected people ahead of them
yeah right and so this is something that
despite but we're just talking about
religious beliefs do they actually
believe what is in their text yeah Amon
the Quran Allah says that they worship
thee you know they call Jose are the son
of God right and they worship Him this
is part of shirk right so we have to I'm
bringing this up because a lot of people
will say that you know there were
Abrahamic faiths Islam Judaism
Christianity and reality the only truly
Abrahamic faith is Islam because we're
the only faith that follows what Abraham
peace be upon him has been spreading and
was about few
or tell hey pure monotheism worship of
God but that message has been corrupted
and so how can we consider even one
Quran in the Quran Allah says that
Abraham was not a Jew he was not a
Christian he was a Hanif he was a Muslim
and and so we have to be aware of this
but from a Dowa perspective it's a very
powerful thing to say that Islam is the
only monotheistic religion Islam is the
only religion that recognizes one
creator one transcendent creator that is
all merciful that all-knowing the all
loving and other religions don't have
that concept yeah it's a misconception
to say that other religions are
monotheistic because they're not but
then the main thing so Dean the way of
life that we live doesn't call us to
hate the particular group of people
because they're a particular group of
people at the door of mercy from of
Islam is open for everybody that's true
yeah the door of mercy so what do we
mean by hate okay if we don't hate a
person in this life to such an extent
that we can never love them later right
because people can change if someone is
truly a vile person and truly you know
hates God it hates all goodness
blasphemes God worship has worships the
lowest of idols yeah we we don't love
that person
we may even hate them that's I think
that's fine okay we we should hate Cofer
we should hate the action action action
yeah and then the person who's engaged
in it like I mean are we gonna say that
we love everyone unconditionally no you
can't say unconditionally no no but you
had like for example Abu Talib right so
you had the Prophet SAW sums uncle who's
he died on worshipping idols right
ancestors but the Prophet saws loved his
uncle all right what about Abu jahil Abu
jahil
now that's different story that's a good
example so now that's family but now
look good we hate Abu jahil
you can hate them but yes that's
balanced that's the balance that's the
beauty of Islam so I like what you said
that that where you have that balance
that now you don't hate someone
to extreme because at anytime someone
can leave paganism they can leave the
worship of human beings money dollars
materialism and they can turn because
the door of mercy to the Creator is
always open right right you can once a
person accepts the truth and it starts
manifesting that then it's nothing but
love what one ayah that comes to mind
will move on we is in the Quran that
trumps because a lot of times people
will throw out things out of context is
chapter 60 verse a to the crime I
believe that's it where a God Almighty's
saying that law God the Creator Allah
does not forbid you from dealing justly
and being kind with those who have not
fought you and persecuted you because of
your Deen your your religion or try to
driven you drive you out of your homes
yeah that's a very amazing principle
yeah right that we treat people justly
we treat people well even when if we
don't share the same faith but this is
not something that is found in all
religions yeah right
and you you have that kind of tribalism
a Subbiah in other faiths and so I think
I like to emphasize these differences
yeah
because this is my style of Dawa because
I want to show people that this is
distinct though what Islam calls to is
distinct from everything else because if
we constantly are portraying Islam as
equal equal equivalent the same you know
this it's all good you know we all
believe in the same stuff then people
will say okay well I can choose the a or
b I can choose Islam or I can choose
like you know everything else that I've
been following I'll just do ever its
most familiar to me and convenient for
me like though like the example people
give we're all like spokes on a wheel
all headed to the same direction right
but Islam I mean it makes sense that
look the Christian comes to me you know
I had a born-again Christian friend we'd
go back and forth and I respected the
fact that he told me he was he
legitimately fear for me and a nice and
we got the elephant out of the room and
he said look if you don't believe Jesus
is your Lord and Savior he died for your
sins you going to Hellfire so thank you
very much we got that other yeah but
it's LOM says the same thing I mean it's
tells that if you don't submit your will
to the creator of the heavens and earth
and there's a clear verse in the ayah in
the Quran
where Allah is making it clear the only
Deen way of life acceptable in front of
the Creator is submission to his will
that's it
and then the other Iowa megabyte
aggregator lease Lama Dean made falafel
au cobalamin hua hua terminal how saline
that if anyone chooses any other Dean
way of life other than submission is
surrender to the creator of heavens and
earth one word Islam is it won't be
accepted and in the hereafter you're
gonna be amongst the losers it's clear
so the people think that they own
themselves they feel entitled like I'm
my own person when the reality is no we
are owned by our Creator our Creator has
created us do we as Allah says no quran
surat or did they create themselves or
did they come from nothing right or did
they come from nothing or were they
themselves the Creator right a loss
isn't a Quran so we didn't create
ourselves and we didn't come from
nothing that makes no sense so who
created us who put us here in this world
so whoever does done that owns us right
so we have no rights to ourselves Hey
that's why we have to submit that's why
we have to accept guidance and recognize
that otherwise I mean there are
consequences
yeah right you can obey the boss at work
I mean what about your Creator it's not
Burger King heavy your own Lama is not
good in all caps well you're now gone
because you did not follow the all-caps
rule and you're being a troll yeah it's
not Christianity okay I understand that
there's I'll just read you a part of the
Bible it says basically if you preach
things outside of Christianity it's not
good okay the differences are less
extreme than some churches having a
female at the pulpit promoting gay pride
uh
entering into usury all this yeah you
could read the Koran in a weekend
fantastic book I highly doubt I could
read the Quran in a weekend guys not
kill Muslims but the Quran calls for the
entire world to submit or die I mean the
Bible says that - it's not submitter
diets that God kills you right or did
the Muslims get to go no Harlan doesn't
say that was he talking about my
this submit or die like I said it has
nothing no basis and any part of Islam
and even in Islamic history show me like
where was this principle enacted
where was this principle enacted like
we're not trying to be apologists right
I'm the farthest person from being
someone who apologizes for his lung as
hopefully you've gotten that sentence if
you look at the history of the Prophet
peace be upon him and the Companions of
the Sahaba the whole affair ishida and
the rightly guided caliphs they were not
massacring people getting them to submit
otherwise you're going to die submit or
die so this is just a myth and it makes
no sense yeah but there are consequences
in in the hereafter we are I mean
obviously to deal just like the ayah
that that we brought up dealing fairly
justly being kind to people this is a
part of our Deen about Islam but at the
same time going off what he was saying
submit or die but at the end if you
choose to follow your lusts your
passions desires worship a human being
next to God
you know worship an idol worship Saints
worship you know setting up a partner
next to God at the end there's a
paradise in the Hellfire
if you choose and you get a clear if the
message comes to you I know this
authentic hadith where the prophet saw
some peace and blessings be upon him
said that whoever hears of me I'm
paraphrasing hadith you know a Jew
Christian whoever pagan and rejects me
right that person will suffer the
consequences in the next life now we can
say hold on what did you hear about him
is that a clear understanding that he is
indeed the last final messenger or
you've getting your information from
from Lauder Crowder or some of these
other hate provocateurs yeah I mean
we're living in an environment where
unfortunately it's a very unique time in
history where religion has been made to
seem like such a backwards thing just
across the board like why would you even
want to be a religious person like why
would you even want to call yourself a
Muslim Christian or Jew unfortunately
that's really the fastest-growing
orientation ideological Orion
people are becoming what's called nons
right what is that nons
non's non-affiliated yeah I believe in
God as a concept but I'm just spirit but
I'm just spiritual this is actually the
fastest growing demographic yeah in the
West and so when you have this kind of
anti religion anti tradition environment
people are apathetic they don't want to
okay you hear about Muhammad well a
slice on why don't you read him about
him why don't you what is his life about
what is his teaching about like he's
just saying it himself
Owen Benjamin that I don't have time to
read the Quran I don't want to even
approach it and we analyze that but you
have all this apathy that is preventing
people from actually exploring and
learning whereas in the past it wouldn't
be like this you have how many major
religions you have a religion that has
dominating in terms of population
one-fourth of the planet and you don't
want to know the basics of what they
believe you don't want to know the
basics of what they are following so
this is unheard of like in our period
yeah okay you have Muhammad peace be
upon him all religions are basically the
same everything is you know who cares
there's not gonna be a very it's not
gonna move the needle in my life to
follow the teachings of this ancient
book chloral you you just pretty much
making up your own religion so you
become your becoming your own God in a
sense yes you're following your whims
and desires as mediated by dominant
culture people are leaving themselves so
vulnerable to being influenced by the
media by the government by these
corporations we were talking about this
earlier about how people can be
manipulated into eating fast food food
that's gonna kill them that's going to
cost cancer that's kind of cause obesity
that's going to cause heart disease why
would a person make a decision that's so
contrary to his own interests his health
his life it's because he's manipulated
it's he's been instead that's what
happens when there's no guidance when
you don't have that anchor holding you
down to something then you just move
with the tides and it's easy for someone
to come and just drag you
in their direction to manipulate you but
when you have Dean when you have truth
when you have that connection to God
that's your anchor you're not going to
be influenced you're gonna know that
this is you're taking me in the wrong
direction and I don't care if all of
society I don't care if all the culture
the whole world is going in a certain
direction the tide is pulling them in
that way I'm anchored I have my you know
my star my North Star that's guiding me
to the right path so awful must a team I
mean none of this would stuff we're
discussing is it just it goes with the
fitara in the common sense and someone
like Owen Benjamin if he watches this
god willing he does it just connects I
mean but the thing is now it's like okay
am I gonna like stick to what my parents
you know my culture what I was brought
up upon or am I really am i sincere and
I'm gonna do what God Almighty wants me
to do that's like like am I gonna
everyone has to make that decision it
doesn't matter if you're Muslim or
non-muslim everyone comes to that point
in their life am I going to choose my
own desires what I want or am I going to
choose what God wants everyone has to
face and so hopefully God willing this
can be of some benefit to him and let's
continue on I probably should read the
Koran but uh from what I know from
people I do trust he had a shift there
he said don't hold your breath but nice
Islam is not an iteration of Judaism
that isn't true
you're lying part you read said that
Jesus was sent
I will cast terror into the hearts of
those who disbelieve so strike them upon
the necks and strike them from every
fingertip don't know context of war oh
and read the letter before after okay
this I is miss I mean they quoted they
don't say that the ayah the verse before
it is read it's clearly the context of
war but there is an idea here that is
important about fear fear of Islam and
we talked about it earlier when you said
that if you realize that something is
the truth the truth can be scary
sometimes the truth can cause fear it
can make you shudder it can make you why
why because that's the beauty and the
the grand nature of truth as it comes
and and hits you in the heart
right and this is something where a lot
of people experience it and sometimes
you know we hear about and hope you know
may Allah allow us to experience it when
you are approaching to your Lord or you
are just reflecting you're looking at
the sky or you're looking at the sunset
and then suddenly something hits you and
and you start crying
why because something is something is
affecting you that's the truth
right that's you that fitrah that we all
have that we're all born with that we
have been created and Allah has asked
asked us before we were born am I not
your Lord
Paolo Bella yes indeed we are you are
our Lord that feeling that every one
every human being has and so that can be
a very scary and indeed terrifying thing
and so aam offers is very clear islam
offers the truth but that can have big
consequences for you as an individual
and that can be a scary scary thing and
those who hate the truth let's be real
do we believe in beliefs in Satan we
believe and Christians believe in demons
and the devil there are people and
creations that hate the truth right even
people who hate the truth and those
people are afraid of the truth they're
afraid of Islam they're the enemies of
the truth in Islam and so Islam and and
the Prophet peace be upon him strike
terror in the hearts of those who hate
the truth mm-hmm and I mean this is not
something that we should water down or
shy away from yeah Islam can be a
terrifying thing to those who hate the
truth to those who are evil to those who
don't want to change yeah but this
particular and many of the the verses in
the Quran what he can do what he should
do he should read the Quran but if there
he comes to something but these these
haters out there you just throw random
verses out there read the before read
the I have to read the context it's got
very simple formula it's going to be
difficult I'll be really honest and
really real because we are in and this
is what my research focuses on
writing in my teaching we're in a
context that I'll characterize as a
secular context okay the idea of God it
has been so distorted the idea of
tradition and religion has been so
distorted and other values have been
imposed on people in in the world today
and so if you are been you've been
indoctrinated and then you open a book
like the Quran as much of it is going to
offend and it's going because you've
been brainwashed you've been brainwashed
so you need to detox if you can okay for
for certain verses obviously the core
message is so powerful that there anyone
at anytime no matter the level of
brainwashing can recognize the truth but
other things okay like for example Allah
says that God says that men can't have
more than one wife okay but women cannot
have more than one husband so if you've
been indoctrinated with a certain modern
ideology that is going to be very
offensive this I mean this went on for
for hundreds of years for sure so why
didn't anyone else find a problem is
because with this non-muslims as well no
one had a problem with the idea that man
could have multiple wives I mean some
Christians did some Orthodox Christians
did in Europe this was one of the main
things that the attack but was based on
a feel theology not on the basis of
ethics like Oh a good person would never
have more than one wife anyway that's
that's a separate discussion there's a
lot of details there but the question is
today people are objecting to these
different verses of the Quran on the
basis of indoctrination philosophical
ideological indoctrination yeah and so
that's a reality that no matter how much
context you're reading you're still
going to have this problem unless you
address the ideology and that's what I
try to do I try to attack the ideology
that whatever is telling you that you
know it's immoral unethical for a man to
have
more than one light and the Prophet
peace be upon him had more than one wife
that what is affecting you is wrong yeah
not Islam that's wrong so you can
compare it like if you have two glasses
of water one is the pure water and the
other one is just full of chemicals
toxins is just filthy
you've been drinking the filthy water if
you start drinking the pure good water
you might throw up at first yeah that's
bad it takes bet but do you stop
drinking the good water the pure water
no you got to detox right so this is an
example that you can relate to this
truth that comes to you exactly exactly
I mean all of the on top topic of jihad
on the topic of women's rights on the
topic of pluralism versus you know my
religious minorities all these issues
there's been such entire nation and and
toxic ideas that you have to get beyond
otherwise you're gonna have a lot
problems with a lot of aspects of Islam
but we have to be careful we can't just
apologize
we can't distort the teachings of Islam
to make it more palatable to people
because then what are they ending up
with they're ending up with a distorted
version of Islam that's not true Islam
you're just it you you've only accepted
a whitewashed version of Islam but there
is nothing if you look at Islam properly
holistically that it oppresses human
beings human beings there is nothing in
there you might not understand it
properly but Islam is there to bring
contentment peace justice all of the
things that make a society run
beautifully there's nothing in there
that's bringing harm to yourself or
society right but how will you recognize
how will you recognize it we gotta go to
the detox
yep the detox but yeah you have to to a
certain extent like recognize that the
human mind is limited yeah right yeah
and so when it comes to the US alike the
main core of tawheed when it comes
worshipping your Creator alone not
associating partners with him that one
everyone understands you can accept and
it makes perfect logical sense but some
of the the food
the the branch issues today then those
require more explanation require more
detail here's here's a true story just
today and then I think this can connect
with this real story he said that he's
going through a divorce and his wife
left him and then he opened up and said
that she ended up cheating on him
and he was actually hiring a trainer to
train his wife now right away I wanted
to cry almost man I was like this is
just like but I started to think I felt
really bad for him but I started to
think look at the beauty of the Dean
like relations between opposite genders
you know the province awesome said a man
and woman is not alone but Shaitaan is
the third not just so like opposite to
the culture today it's just like if you
take these precautionary steps
that's a murse that would have been a
mercy to potentially saving you and your
family but people don't have this yeah
they don't have it like this is
something that you're whole it's not
just your life that's affected by
infidelity and the breakup of your
family it's not just you and your family
it's the whole society she's affected by
this the whole a whole nation whole
civilization can be brought down and you
have historians non-muslim historians
who have written about this about how
when the values in society are corrupted
and you see more sexual deviance and
people are falling into certain kinds of
sexual practices and there's no stable
idea of marriage people are falling like
divorcing left and right then
civilization collapses and you have
someone like Edward Gibbon who is a
Christian historian European historian
who talks about the rise and fall of
civilization and this is his basic
sociological theory that these small
things that happen on the micro level
where it's just a question of are you
following your desires affects everyone
and so when you look at the guidelines
within Islam that you won't find in any
other religion on gender relations
the hijab when it comes to even going to
some of the things that the West really
likes to hate like when it comes to
punishments whoo dude for those who have
committed adultery zina okay those are
really really important because they are
such a huge deterrent to that kind of
behavior if you know that you're
practicing this kind of sexual behavior
outside the bonds of marriage you're
going to face a criminal charge and
punishment you know given that there's
an investigation and charges are brought
and you're judged in a fair trial by the
kadhi and you can be punished
then you're gonna avoid that behavior
and you have a society that is based on
that kind of value that's uphol upheld
by the authorities by the law how much
more stable is that society going to be
how much more happy families are going
to be look at the children who are born
out of wedlock
this is non-muslim academic scientific
saying the chances of such I'll do is
born to a single mother raised in a
single-mother household is far more
likely to do drugs far more likely to
fall into crime far more likely to drop
out of school far more likely to cause
all kinds of social problems
statistically right look at mass
shooters many of them okay are depressed
they're on prescription pills and
they're for depression and they're from
broken families okay so this is a big
deal like this kind of sexual practice
so look how Islam just cuts it from the
root from the removed from the root and
so it's not a victimless crime this is
what some of these secularists and
atheists say oh oh who who cares like if
two people love each other and they
decide to do this kind of behavior it's
a victimless crime they're just doing it
in private bla bla bla bla bla all of
this propaganda the reality recognized
by non-muslims and in the in the core of
the religion and in the Quran and the
show yeah is that this is something that
affects everyone and it has to be cut at
the root mm-hmm let's continue on know
and the distortion of the media whether
it's on your phone or the TV screen or
the movie the mozzie is is always
blowing everybody up and chopping off
heads and all that and then you start
realizing kids are trans you know I
don't like that Islam isn't the Bible
that's a sin you know my faith says that
that is not good but when you look at a
group of people that that I would just
mention coming to Islam is in the Bible
because if you read it just look at the
Lord's Prayer I mean look our Father who
art in heaven hallowed be thy name thy
kingdom come thy will be done this is
Islam all the prophets they did Islam
write or having families that are not
taking loans that are not embracing
sodomy you can't say that's from Satan
as your female pastor is telling
everybody to go by each other how is
that does that make sense in your
twisted mind Muhammad said Satan tricked
him and you're writing the Quran I don't
believe that's true I don't want to talk
about it anymore because I'm not an
expert on it let's let's cover that this
is a common or this is a common attack
that they attack with this one about no
horror Anup Satanic Verses yes called
how do you like to address that so I did
a video on this very recently actually
so this is what has been claimed that
Orientalists really emphasized this
there are some narrations that the
Prophet peace be upon him was reciting
surah of the Quran in front of the
porush in front of the polytheists and
Muslims and it was just a very powerful
recitation and then within that
recitation the Iblees satan threw out
some verses okay that he made up that oh
we are going to bow down and praise
certain idols and then the Prophet SAW I
saw him allegedly recited that
recitation because he thought was from
gibreel from the Archangel Gabriel peace
be upon him so this is the claim
narration it is found within our
tradition but the vast majority of
scholars said that this was fabricated
it is not this is not something that
actually took place the vast majority of
scholars say this fabricated
fabricate but I want to say a little bit
more about this because there are some
scholars who said that it did happen and
this is something that actually did take
place and there is an ayah of the quran
that refers to it that refers to the
fact that we have not sent any messenger
except that satan has thrown in some
falsehood into their recitation and so
on the basis of this ayah some scholars
most notably eben tamiya said that this
is actually an authentic event that
happened but even Tamiya makes a
brilliant brilliant argument and he says
that the fact that this happened
according to him and that this narration
is authentic according to him show
actually gives us more credence in the
Prophet peace be upon him being a
truthful messenger even even though like
this happened why how does that make
sense because this kind of contradictory
or it seems kind of counterintuitive why
would we trust the Prophet peace be upon
him more and revelation more if this
kind of mistake that the Prophet
immediately corrected right after
reciting those wrong verses from Iblees
allegedly then he corrected it and had
the correct recitation gibreel came and
corrected him and the way that I
explained it is that with my kids right
I have four boys and they often will get
into fights and they're rowdy and
they're jumping around and then suddenly
they're young so there'll be a cry of
pain and you know screaming and then
I'll go as a parent I say well what
happened who hit who right who's the
guilty party here and then one of my
son's will always say without fail that
O Muhammad hit me Muhammad do you always
say the same thing right
but then my other son will sometimes
admit he'll say well no I made a mistake
my bed right it was my fault and I made
a mistake here I'm sorry and so
sometimes he'll say he'll blame himself
you'll admit that there's a mistake so
because of this I trust him more okay
because he admits his mistake whereas
the other one is always saying the same
story
no matter what and I know that sometimes
he's the one who clearly like when the
other kid has like a red mark on his
face and he's not the one who threw the
slap so this is how I you know the event
Amy explained it is how I understand it
that if it's true I'm not saying that
this is authentic narration or not but
even if we concede and say okay fine
this is authentic it actually gives more
credence more credibility to the Prophet
peace be upon him because he's admitted
that this was a mistake and and and he
corrected so you go either way yeah the
what you said the consent a majority of
scholars say this is fabricated yeah I
believe this is found in cuppa tea
this is in the history book we're sorry
you know narrate so many so many things
regardless of their veracity yeah so he
has fabricated things weak all levels
that's the nature it's not because
tolerate is is bad or he's trying to
confuse Muslims it's just that was the
nature of the work it was an
encyclopedic kind of reference not to be
taken as oh yeah everything that I'm
saying here happened yeah so then these
scholars say there's no chain directing
because we have that science which they
don't have of authentic authentication
the science of hadith so they're saying
that is there's nothing there it's
fabricated now the other one you can go
either way so the majority of minority I
mean nobody agrees so if he says
something we can't just say yeah we
can't just say he doesn't know what he's
talking about and just throw it out yeah
I mean when we look at his reasoning
yeah he brings solid dalian and then you
gave a great brilliant example like with
with so this just it really it really
doesn't hold much weight at the end yeah
not an expert on it I'm an expert on
human nature and patterns I'm not an
expert on the Koran I'm not an expert on
the Bible many people can take a great
example from him where they talk on
Islam and he was overtly coming out and
he was saying some very very just
malicious things about Islam lies you
know things out of context and he was
spreading a lot of misinformation but
now it's just very amazing to see Owen
Benjamin now he's like most people who
don't know the topic they should come on
sir I just don't know and he's doing
that
yeah you have to have some sincerity to
do that so he made quite a change not
like have certain people paying you
because there's a whole industry that's
a whole different time is a whole
different topic so I think that he's
kind of he's woke in that sense and
maybe he's off the grid now and so he
doesn't maybe have the same strings yeah
how much have you in your in your
research I believe it's like documented
almost like the over of a quarter of a
million dollars annually spent I think
that's a small number of money spent in
the business of bashing Islam I think
much more than much more much more yeah
yeah it's vested interest in making
Aslam look as bad as possible yeah
cran way less than the Bible but I'm
still not capable of having these
conversations I know that Muslims I know
follow God and truth more than many many
many Christians I know that are pledging
their soul to the nation of Israel debt
in sodomy and that's a fact and you can
say all you want but when people are
just like oh it's dirty flea-bitten
desert-dwelling it's like you bombed
them for 25 years because of 9/11 and
you shamelessly are just gonna keep
slandering 9/11 happens and then we go
into two countries one of which we're
already there and we haven't left
it's just bombs away because Israel
wants us to and you can sit there and
just keep condemning these people you
don't even know that you've never met
that they're they've watched their
families guys Obama was drone striking
weddings have you ever been to a wedding
and seeing everyone's skin melt I have
it I'm blessed that I've never seen
everyone's skin melt off because a robot
in the sky found a cell phone in
someone's pocket your carriers converted
died can we say something about that
it's not just 20 years since 9/11 that
Muslims have been bombed it is
generations okay when did the colonial
period start it started in eight
hundred right and that's the beginning
of the invasion of Muslim lands by the
French and the British and also the
Dutch and so you had genocide okay look
at and and some of it is very documented
in gory grim details look at some of the
pictures coming from Algeria and what
the French were doing you have French
soldiers with severed heads of believers
right pictures of women raped women who
have just been raped Muslim believers by
these French savages right who have come
to supposedly civilize the Muslims right
and so you have this history over 200
years of colonialism
that's ravaged the Muslim world not only
physically but also intellectually also
spiritually okay so this is the context
that we are we're seeing the fruits of
that now it doesn't end right because
you have puppet leaders that have been
installed in all of these Muslim
countries right divide and conquer
strategy and these puppets are you know
Muslim by name but they're getting all
their money and their weapons and their
influence from the West and their whole
job is to suppress Muslims suppress
Islam be a secular dictator right don't
let you know men grow their beards don't
what you know let women wear new cob
cover themselves properly we need to
advance you know quote unquote human
rights so forth what they really mean
when they say advancing human rights
they mean advancing Western culture and
Western ideology that's what they really
mean and so they've obliterated entire
villages right is what is Israel is
doing to Philistine is just a small
sample of what has happened throughout
the history of colonialism what the
Serbs did to Bosnia that is just a
branch of this project against the
Muslim world and so he is by saying 20
years I'm glad that he's saying this but
it's just like a tip of the iceberg tip
of the iceberg
Wow Owens getting we get some good
information to Owen yeah Shalala okay
that's not to do that I've asked you not
to do that and you still can't stop
you're gone because you can't listen
well I know who can follow follow basic
rules of just being a guest in someone's
chat Muslims if I told a Muslim to stop
bashing Christians that's what they
would do they would stop and they
probably would have even done it in the
first place
because they're not about wealth and
children I asked you to stop debating
the Koran and you wouldn't stop you are
not that is not the Word of God you're
here this is my chat it's like follow
basic etiquette bro you're gonna try and
preach with your condemnation I'm sick
of it it kept me from God for decades I
was raised Catholic where there was no
God in that church none zero was about
money and control barely cracked the
Bible guys so I could spot it like that
if I asked a Muslim just to out of like
you're in my home don't do this don't
say this they would say okay so what
you're doing is you're dramatizing your
lack of God through your religion which
you profess to be Christian you're
giving Christianity a bad name if you're
a guest in someone's home and as they
say listen I do not want to discuss this
endlessly and someone just goes oh uh
they're kaffir you don't think I've
heard that I was Steven Crowder's head
writer for six months I've heard all the
[ __ ] you're taking it out of context
I know about calf ears and all that [ __ ]
Sharia law
yeah non-believers pay more and this
that dude of course we're under Jewish
Sharia right now the IRS takes more than
half you won't admit that instead you're
you're more likely just being like I
died for Israel if we bless Israel God
blesses us with our big houses your
satanic you think the Christianity means
getting a big old airplane I've asked
you not to do it I'll do a whole thing
Rael have
mom on here and we'll talk it out we'll
talk about I will have you guys email me
specific sections and we'll have someone
explain it and if we catch them lying
we'd never have to trust it again he
says something brilliant I'd have an
imam come on we invited Joe Rogan louder
Crowder you know people like that to go
ahead and bring a someone who like
yourself someone who specializes in this
field to come on and let's have a nice
dialogue a nice talk about it ask those
tough questions and we're still waiting
they haven't done that yet but someone
who was a writer for for louder from
Crowder friend of Joe Rogan's you know
it seems like he's had an awakening and
he's saying the right things now yeah I
don't think that what he's saying now is
similar to what Joe Rogan has ever said
or what sorry what Joe Rogan or Crowder
Crowder doesn't talk like this he's
saying things that those two would even
dream of saying so mashallah you know
may Allah guide him and if he is true to
that he's actually going to bring
someone knowledgeable to to speak about
these issues I think that'd be
beneficial for him it'll be beneficial
for viewers a couple points that he
mentioned we can quickly just touch upon
those Coffee it he they throw that out
yeah fair yeah yeah what's it just means
someone who is you know non-muslim
someone who is rejected okay so like
we're non-christian is that an insult
it's just a descriptive term but I mean
there is the connotation that okay this
is someone who has denied the truth but
it's not in the sense that okay you're
in a different class and you can never
be redeemed or you can never have
guidance or you can never have you know
being able to become a Muslim and to be
you know accepted as a Muslim not like a
legal alien illegal alien so comfort
someone who who covers up the conceals
like a farmer he does prove it like so
someone who's covering up the truth
right they they use these derogatory
terms it's I believe another Christian
term infidel yes that was a Christian
and it's coming from the context of the
Crusades the Inquisition's and
Reconquista so this is something that is
from their tradition of okay you're not
Christian therefore believe otherwise
yeah except the trendy otherwise we're
going to or not even accept the Trinity
except like this particular Creed
because even amongst Trinitarians
there's all kinds of different yeah
Creed so it's very if you're coming from
that context this is why arguably why
liberalism and secularism came out of
Europe and atheism modern atheism is a
European concept it's not something you
don't find within the Muslim world
atheism generating an atheistic thought
it's been imported now and so now you
find atheists in the Muslim world but
they're borrowing from European but that
intellectual thought of atheism is
coming from Europe why because they had
so much conflict and war and bloodshed
based on like different sectarian
disputes and so that's created this
hatred of religion but they paint all
religions as being having that same kind
of dynamic having that same kind of
history same bloodthirstiness and that's
how people become secular but if we show
them that Islam is not like that it
doesn't have that history doesn't have
that kind of bloodlust then that can be
a door for guidance insha Allah
Oh Owen Benjamin getting some love here
from the Muslims coming directly to you
and all those that follow you and before
we press play were almost done
Sharia Sharia is ten commandments it's
mentioned over 200 sometimes in the
Bible it's it's thrown out there like
something foreign boogeyman again come
to get you Jesus taught it Moses taught
it Sharia the way that I explained
Sharia is that if you believe in a
loving merciful God and you believe that
he's created us with a purpose on this
earth then you believe necessarily that
he's also saying guidance okay what kind
of loving God would send human beings
blindly without any direction for their
family for their parenting for their
communities for their government okay
further economic
right all these different facets of life
a merciful God logically would send
guidance okay and that's what Sharia is
that's the path right the path sorrow
must stop being the straight path and so
it doesn't the the again the Christian
concept that religion only applies to
your personal life just who you are as
an individual and maybe if you're a
conservative Christian then you also
think that religion applies to your
family like how husbands and wives
should be with their children and so
forth but Islam expands that right yeah
guidance is not just for you as an
individual your marriage your family how
about your community okay what guidance
is there for how to be in the communal
context what guidance is there on the
economic level what guidance is there on
the governmental level law in order
these are all important crucial aspects
of human life okay doesn't God want us
to be happy you believe in a loving
merciful God okay
so then those kinds of that kind of
guidance is needed in all he's talking
about interest right that's something
economic it has nothing to do with your
personal woken up to that also
yeah he's woken up to that so where's
God's guidance if you're a secularist do
you think that oh well philosophers will
just think like what's the best way that
human beings can live life I don't trust
as someone who has a graduate degree in
philosophy I don't trust what people
what philosophers have to say about how
to live your life and so you want based
an entire civilization on that no we
have the show yeah we're blessed to have
God send us guidance law ethics it's not
just formal law it's also ethics it's
how to be in the world
so what Moses brought was Sharia the Ten
Commandments yes is the guidance is that
that guidance from the all-loving allah
dhu of the Creator that was in earth
what jesus brought in its original we
don't have the original today it's been
changed that's why the law sent the last
and final message of Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessing be upon him with that
guidance it's it's there but they throw
these terms and you're not used to these
terms and now you get scared and all the
like the history of Christianity is in
the political context you had the
corrupt Church he mentioned it right in
Robin an Affleck Church that made a deal
with the devil basically saying that
look we'll have our domain and you have
your domain right we're we're not going
to step on your toes you don't step on
our toes we'll have this separation of
church and state as deal it's a business
deal right and so that's where that's
arguably it's very complicated academic
yeah well I won't bore you but that's
arguably the origins of this kind of
secularism that we have today in Islam
right we don't have the scholars were
persecuted right Islamic scholars Imam
Ahmed Imam Malik all of the major
scholars were persecuted because the
Sultan the Sultan would say look rubber
stamp and endorse religiously endorsed
my corruption right religiously endorsed
me as a leader and they wouldn't do it
they'd say no I don't want to have
anything to do with that I want corrupt
and confuse people by mixing and so so
many amazing stories where imam ahmed
for example wouldn't accept gifts right
the Sultan sent him all of the this kind
of delicious sweets and bread and food
and he said no I'm not going to accept
accept any of this is one of the great
scholars of Islam right and so then they
took those gift gifts and they threw it
in the river and then Imam Ahmed
wouldn't eat any fish that was caught in
that river just on the basis of he
wanted to keep it pure right he doesn't
want anything to do benefit in any way
from this kind of gift or and this kind
of bribe essentially because he's
worried about what he's going to say to
Allah
on the day of judgment did you do
anything to justify the corruption of
these leaders and so we don't have this
kind of concept as Muslims we don't have
this kind of negative attitude of our
religious leaders we don't have this
negative we don't have this bad
suspicion you find that in Christianity
and Judaism in Judaism they considered
their prophets
they considered Moses they considered
all of the Old Testament prophets to be
corrupt like lot all right to be corrupt
and to caught do even vile kinds of
behavior get drunk you know commit
incestuous acts yeah but we don't have
that in Islam we understand that the MBA
the prophets were all pure yeah and our
Imams are inheritors of the prophets and
and they the the leaders of them are all
pure right and so this is we don't have
the same problems that Christians have
and Jews have in this day and age all
right let's go for hamdulillah let's go
on with Owen Benjamin here that's how it
works its terms and conditions Muslims
in name only committing acts of violence
it does not condemn Islam because if
that's true then a lot of Christians are
condemning Christianity which I will not
abide by because I love Jesus Christ
that's a fact I have deep love for Jesus
Christ so if you hold Muslims to the
standard in which you do not follow
yourself you are humiliating my lord get
the fear the beatings we left work we
love Jesus Christ more okay we love
Jesus Christ more as Muslims and we're
expecting him to come and he will come
the Messiah will come and he'll defeat
the Antichrist and we have that belief
we believe it and in such an a great
extent that even next to the Prophet
peace be upon him his grave in Medina
next to him is an open grave who is that
grave reserved for that grave is
reserved for the Messiah Jesus peace be
upon him when he comes he's going to
live and he's going to rule he's going
to break the cross he's going to kill
the pig right pork and he is going to
rule with justice and God's law and then
he'll live a life and then he'll pass
away he's the promised Messiah that
everyone is waiting for and that's Jesus
Christ and so we have that plot that
grave next to the Prophet peace be on
Muhammad and so we actually love Jesus
much more than Christians do we don't
attribute lies to
Jesus and say that he was God or that he
was the creator or God killed himself to
save like all of these missus like
stories we don't have that we we pray
like Jesus prayed look at what the New
Testament says about Jesus praying
prostrating I had a friend in college a
Christian friend
and he he was more conservative and
evangelical and we would talk about
religion sometimes I asked him like well
what makes you interested in Islam and
he said that you know I really am moved
by prostration by sujood like you guys
are putting to pray to your Lord you're
putting your forehead your face on the
floor and that's something that
Christian we don't do that we don't have
that and that's something that really I
admire about Islam and then it was
interesting because later we were in the
dorm at Harvard watching some video of a
famous convert to Islam Muslim preacher
and he was talking about his story why
he became Muslim and as he's describing
he's saying that I watched Muslims
prostrate and putting their heads on the
ground this is on YouTube he's speaking
this and then this Christian friend
walks in just right at that moment and
hears this you know from this person and
from this Muslim so so Paula this is
something that the beauty of Islam is
easily recognizable and if Christians
look in their own books and they look at
Jesus Christ his life what he is
preaching his words not what came later
in the in the Gospels after with Paul
and so forth okay they look at what
actually Jesus is preaching in the Bible
if they look at the Old Testament and
see they can read Muhammad in the Bible
other books that talk about Islam in the
Bible they all the signs are there these
are all signs right ayat that will lead
someone to the truth and so we have good
expectation and good hopes for everyone
all Christians all Christians everyone
in the world that the truth is there for
you and we're gonna open welcomed you
with open arms
you heard you heard that Owen I mean and
all the followers are on all the
Christians out there that the Muslims
have a deep love and reverence for Jesus
there's a whole chapter named
after his Blessed Mother Mary you talked
about we greet like Jesus peace be with
you circumcised like jesus pray like
Jesus and most of all we worship the one
God the same way Jesus did not a Trinity
he never did that he worshiped the one
and only one creator
let's all go ahead and finish up here
until order is resumes you guys got to
see something now this is interesting
you we went from him he's even got a
beard now and he and he's gonna do
something that's gonna just blow Owens
about to start doing something that's
even more fascinating check this out
alright
you guys got to see some of the comments
I get just for saying that Christian
he's closer to Islam that it is Judaism
I'm gonna start saying peace be upon him
when I say Muhammad just troll people
man Muhammad peace be upon him I'm just
gonna Muhammad peace be upon him I'm
gonna start saying that in front of
Christian Zionists and Jews they're
gonna lose their mind well have it peace
be upon him I'm like you worship money
that's our friend Owen Benjamin huh God
willing may Allah the creator of the
heavens and earth and Aramaic jesus
called maloha Elohim this is the
all-merciful loving you ask him for
guidance and he will guide you and
inshallah you'll be saying peace be upon
all of them sincerely from your heart
and you will be one who has submitted
his will to the Creator that happens in
the earth we pray that Allah opens your
heart and guides you to the truth
and are we so blessed that we have Islam
company that we so blessed that you know
I just something certain moments you
just hit you and you recognize that
other people are missing out and Allah
has given us this beautiful gift of
Islam and we want to share it you wanted
to share it didn't want others to see
that and to enjoy the fruits of that in
their lives and in the Hereafter and
that when I when I when I shared this
story with just today when when he was
sharing what had happened to him I felt
literally like I felt like really bad
man I felt like you know I'm literally
gonna cry but I felt like inside you get
those like that that chill like man this
is you felt really bad for him he lost
you got kids
she went off and and you're like man
this deem you know if you had it just
those preventative things that you can
do the tools Islam gives you this the
blueprint for life that if you follow it
you'll be successful in life you know
things will happen divorce it can
happens not that like in Christianity
where you're actually you're not allowed
to get divorced right it's not a sin in
Islam yeah it's not a sin in Islam but
it gives you the tools that you will
function better and navigate through all
of these challenges in life from the
small to the big you gave some great
examples earlier you know them from the
minuscule to the Madame micro to the
macro things that come up the challenges
where people don't have those things and
you know you see it and you like wow
this actually I have something here that
can help you you know I mean but we
don't look at the corruption with the
way women dress and pornography and the
kind of shamelessness like this is
something that any Christian any
god-fearing Christian can see that this
is so harmful and it's on a macro level
and so how can you criticize as a
Christian how can you Kim criticized he
jab
how can you criticize modesty in Islam
look at even your depictions of the
Virgin Mary which again we believe
obviously she's wearing hijab she's
wearing hijab Yeah right and so the
value of this and the value of modesty
gender relations all of this is clear
truth truth after truth after truth and
it's been preserved right it hasn't been
distorted why okay as you as a Christian
reflect why isn't covering the head
scene is so important nowadays okay
amongst Christians well you have the
preacher's wife in all this kind of
makeup and she's even getting plastic
surgery because she has to look good and
raised those millions of dollars for her
private jet right that he brings up
actually on already he said I you think
Christianity is about having a big plane
yeah prosperity gospel so how does it
have anything to do with your religion
right if you understand the value of
modesty if you're seeing the Virgin Mary
who has that who has preserved that slum
so all of these stereotypes the main
things they want to criticize Islam for
and we can go through a list all of
those become the strongest proofs for
Islam yeah that Islam is the truth okay
this is my experience if you're gonna
look at I mean the ultimate miracle
because Jesus during his time he had
miracles to prove that he was indeed who
he said he was a messenger he never
claimed and we give the hundred thousand
dollar challenge are you with it if
someone can produce any authentic
statement where Jesus says I am God
worship me right here today would you
pay two hundred thousand dollars yeah so
we got again another hundred thousand
dollar challenge but he did call people
to submit their will to the creator of
the heavens and earth it's there the
proof that he was a messenger during his
time Moses during his time then to sum
it up today if you want to substantiate
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him was indeed who he said he
was and God's who God said he was you
look at the Quran genuinely sincerely
then you look at Prophet Muhammad's life
his Sita his the history I mean you have
an in the Quran you have things that are
mentioned in there there's no way that
him or a group of men could have come up
with these things the authenticity of
the Quran no they've done analysis
they've got an analysis right using
computer linguistics this is a research
paper maybe I can give you the link for
the video but they did computer analysis
because now you can and analyze a piece
of writing or you can analyze two pieces
of writing and tell if it's from the
same author because even if you're
trying to fake it like I'm trying to
pretend like I'm gonna impersonating
Eddie and I'm writing a letter they can
look at the analysis and compare that
letter that I'm impersonating you and
compare it with something that else I've
written and know okay this is actually
Eddie or not right you can do computer
analysis of that and so what they've
done is they've taken the Quran all of
the verses of the Quran and they've
taken the statements of the Prophet
peace be upon him so I so I'm the hadith
and they've compared them is this the
same author is the author of hadith the
same as the author of the part because
this is what atheist and the non-muslims
claimed that the product peace Bahamut
so I some has
the Quran by his own hand they've done
the analysis and it's definitive this is
not the same law look at that and that's
not a war-cry that just praising the
Creator that happens there like you say
hallelujah huh look at that that is
amazing think about that only think
about that think about that so they've
done this analysis we're differentiating
because we have the statements authentic
statements from Prophet Muhammad his
speech then you have the Quran this is
the verbatim words of the Almighty
they've distinguished it and you can
test even even someone just reading the
Quran and then reading the statements of
the Prophet peace be upon him in the
hadith yeah you can tell even if you
even in the English translation you can
tell us not the same style it's not the
same way of writing if you know Arabic
it's even more clear and I've had non
Muslim Arabs like Arab Christians from
Lebanon and other other places admit
that I've read the Quran and it's just
beautiful there's nothing like it and
there's no comparison and it's very
clear that the hadith is not the same
author as the Quran
yeah and they won't take the extra step
and admit that okay this is from Allah
so what's the conclusion of that ok this
Quran is from the Creator from Allah
they won't because of maybe lack of
sincerity or whatever but they admit it
at least and now there's even computer
linguistic analysis because there's
forensic studies it's a whole field in
literature it's a big deal because they
want to authenticate did Shakespeare
really write Hamlet did Shakespeare
really write Romeo and Juliet and so
they've done using computer technology
now to do that kind of analysis there
are theories that Shakespeare didn't
actually write many of the works that
are attributed to him but that same
technology has been used to compare
Quran and hadith and have shown that
they don't have the same author
definitively and so what can you
conclude the rational person will
conclude that ok in 23 years of the
Prophet peace be upon him his life in
his career
what is he has all of these statements
that have been recorded by the people
around him he was illiterate he would
didn't know how to read and write so
where did this book come from yeah this
makes sense that someone collaborated
over 23 years to reveal it or to publish
it or whatever many people think of like
Nostradamus
Saddam is he made some vague predictions
the majority of things they weren't
correct one thing or they're so vague
they're so vague so now people like put
him up on some kind of pedestal but if
if prophet muhammad saw if he made one
prediction or he said something in the
crown that's not accurate it's a
contradiction clearly than you discredit
the whole thing but you don't find it so
not only from the Quran then you study
his life and you see the the prophecies
things that are just clear it's not
vague clear things in there like for
instance what comes to mind and Owen can
look this up himself you know where the
prophet saw some predicted that he'll
come a time when the barefoot Arab will
be competing and building the fall bill
tall buildings right I would have known
that at that time for instance it's it's
it's something so specific yeah and it's
so unexpected yeah okay because I'll
tell you why the what you're referring
to is the hadith this is the famous
hadith of gibreel where Gabriel came and
asked the Prophet peace be upon him what
is Islam what is iman what is a sign and
I want to belabor it but then he asked
him what are when is the hour the
Prophet Sawa says the questioner knows
as little as the one being questioned
and then what is what are the signs of
the day of judgment and so the product
piece of Johan gave some signs one of
them being that one of the signs that
the day of judgment is near is that
their foot bed winds will be competing
with each other to construct you know
tall buildings where's the tallest
building now it's in the way your worst
cliff all right yeah okay so but why
this is it's very specific it's not just
some vague notion Nostradamus kind of
prediction or a prophecy like oh there's
gonna be some war there's there have
been war throughout history like that's
not very specific but building Bedouins
are nomadic okay these kind of nomadic
Shepherds they don't have material
they're living in the desert they don't
have civilization buildings are this are
the mark of a civilization the ability
to build tall buildings like the
pyramids of giza for example that's a
sign and now the bigot of Manhattan New
York City and so for better winds to be
able to construe
these high buildings where do they get
the wealth from they didn't know about
oil and time to probably peace be upon
them they didn't know about that kind of
material wealth that was underneath the
desert that we find you know the United
Arab Emirates and Qatar and so forth so
that is something so specific it's
something so unexpected but now we see
it with our eyes and and many other
prophecies of the product peace be upon
him that are like this and so this is
clear proof like this is clear any
rational person weigh the evidence like
what other religion has prophecies about
the last day about the coming of the end
of time so many and so abundant there
are many very vague predictions or
prophecies but in Islam we have the
specifics this is if you take for
instance and the reason I bring up
Nostradamus is to strike that example
let's say you have a red bean and a
green bean the green is that you're
right accurate if you put just one over
here that's not you discredit the whole
thing Nostradamus would have been just
you know right discredited a long time
ago but you have all these things like
the human development of the the
development of human being in the embryo
like from early stages like in the Quran
and all the other we know the the signs
that are in there the prophecies so just
keep adding the green beans green beans
green correct correct correct correct
correct right the memorization of the
Quran the authenticity of the Quran so
we know all of that but then you study
his life and you see these prediction we
just named one too many books have been
written about this then you have the
miracles you have motive are that hadith
you know like if someone had seen at a
particular time an accident and event
and you have like 50 people in the room
narrating the same thing 100 people but
then you have we usually boast about
well the Christian usually boasts about
the miracles of Jesus peace be upon him
which we only believe because of the
Quran substantiates it so then you have
the Prophet Muhammad who also did
miracles being able to people taking
would do from the fingers water water
gushing from his fingers abundance of
food also from a small plate seems like
a moon
split the moon splitting the prediction
when the trench was being built the
Battle of the trench right
the striking the rock you know the
prediction for Yemen what else Yemen
Syria sham I mean green being great
meaning yeah correct correct kiss Sarah
when the Bounty Hunter was after him
right and then he had a fall of Persian
Empire and then he told a bounty hunter
that who was chasing him if he goes back
he'll be seeing on the throne he'll be
sitting on the throne of Kistler
bringing the bracelets right right and
then and then sometime later do I think
was omeka Taub's time to the on then
they conquered this and conquered Persia
he was he went out wearing those
bracelets so this is just unbelievable
so Owen Benjamin looking to this and
those people are out there who are
watching us with a sincere heart were
genuine the evidence the green beans all
these pointings like we can I come from
it Sun comprehendible that this would
just be and then at the end when he was
asked you know he was offered like these
politicians they say sell their own
mother's out their souls as many the
majority of whom he was offered the
money the fame the women all of these
things he said no if you put the right
the moon in my right to Lud you know the
Sun in my left no I'm not giving this up
until his message is establish a pure
monotheism yeah so I come from that a
background similar to you where secular
background born Muslim but didn't know
anything about Islam wasn't taken to a
Masjid for most of my life
the first time I went to Friday prayer
was in high school so I was very secular
I came to studying Islam with a sense of
objectivity I'm gonna be as objective as
possible I'm I have a very analytic mind
and I can smell like BS basically yeah
right and so that's why I studied
physics because of that and I study
philosophy and the goal was to be
objective and fair and that's how I came
to Islam because when you actually do
that comparison and that rational
analysis the counting as you said like
in favor of Islam in favor of Islam in
favor of Islam then it becomes
overwhelming
it becomes overwhelming and so this is
the message that we have we there in
Islam there's no conflict between faith
and reason right in Islam we know that
the more rational you are the
more the stronger your belief is gonna
be the stronger your faith your the
stronger your Eman your faith is gonna
be in God hey there's no conflict unlike
if with other religions okay there's no
we don't have that sense of a leap of
faith and a sense okay reason your your
your mind the true pure minds that
hasn't been corrupted by modern
ideologies is going to hit the truth
like an arrow and that's sincerity right
so we we understand that the mind and
the heart and the roar the Neffs these
are all connected and we have to purify
it just like you cure off' i the self we
purify the mind and that leads us to the
truth there's no conflict I want to hit
this point home so Owen can understand
and anyone else who professes that deep
love for God Almighty the Creator Allah
and simply when we say Allah this is the
creator of the heavens the earth and
like I said earlier Jesus called on the
Creator Aloha
Elohim this is because the English
language didn't exist and it's
interesting if you take Jesus and you
take off the J what do you have
ISA ISA ISA ISA this is this is uh who's
mentioned the crowd this is real name so
now to hit home with God Almighty being
the most loving the most merciful Allah
dude as he's called he has the most
beautiful names but one of the things
and the most just that he will not
forgive if you're doing it now if you're
worshiping other than the crater right
now and you turn your way back to him
you'll forgive but if you die on this
Owen or anyone else and we say this out
of genuine concern and love this is the
unforgivable unpardonable act that God
Almighty if you die on this and that's
why I just want to hit home with this
because it's so serious it's like you're
gonna get through the border they made
it so easy you can just get through you
know what I mean and you have to
obviously know the Quran and the Sunnah
to understand this concept but now
they're letting you go just go ahead go
ahead and over here it does this one
thing you got to just stay away from
right don't do this otherwise you're
gonna be banned all right so now you did
this one thing you set up a partner
arrival with God and I give an example
and none of these examples can bring
justice to it because it's it's it's so
it's it's such a vile it's it's so it's
such a horn thing to do that blasphemy
were now imagine someone and maybe you
can you can hit home with it also where
you raise a child and you and you bring
this child up and this child you know
you send it to school you washes diapers
you provide for it you know till they're
grown up and and next thing you know
they get up to thank right at their
graduation after you've done all the
hard work and this does not do justice
to the comparison but just something
that it can stimulate someone just to
think how would you feel now that son
when it got a little girlfriend and he
got out there and he praised the
girlfriend that he's been dating for a
couple of weeks he totally forgot about
his parents you know I mean how would
you explain so he can hit home when we
say [ __ ]
why is this such a grave action that's
somewhat that is unpardonable
unforgivable if you die on it so God is
giving you as your Creator everything
that you have it's like the parent
analogy is kind of understating it and
understand understand God is giving you
every every breath that you take you
can't take a breath every atom in your
body ok ISM is moving by the will of God
and so your existence from moment one
iota of time to the next is by the mercy
and the will of God and so how can you
not be thankful to that God and if that
and your Creator tells you something
okay your Creator says everything that
you can do is open to forgiveness okay
I'm going to send you Commandments don't
do this don't don't steal don't cheat
don't have this kind of do the sexual
behavior and don't eat certain kinds of
food don't do drugs giving these kinds
of Commandments but even those if you
fall and you make mistakes to err is
human right God will forgive you if you
you're sincere and you ask for
forgiveness
right or even if you don't ask for
forgiveness certain things God might
pardon out of his mercy and out of his
his his wisdom but he says that this one
thing this one thing do not do don't
cross this line okay God just has that
one condition
and then everything he gives you all the
ability to recognize that truth with the
fitrah he gives you the fitrah
internally he sends messenger after
messenger after messenger with miracles
okay undeniable miracles even miracles
today we're talking about the prophecies
that have come true true prophecies of
the Prophet peace be on the Quran this
linguistic analysis that I'm referring
to that shows that the divine origin
okay and as a sign of that all of these
evidences to get you to see that this
line is is should not be crossed and
then and then you cross it and then and
then you you know throw that all away
and then you do the one thing that just
shows the kind of revolt against God the
kind this is why it's so satanic okay
this is why it's so satanic because God
is willing to forgive all of these
things and give you all of this leeway
okay to live life and obviously there
are their bad deeds and sins okay but
those you are still you can be forgiven
for but this one thing isn't what Allah
says in the Quran that he will not
forgive is shirk is setting up partners
with God that is how severe it is
because it represents such a rebellion
at its core a rebellion against God and
that's why you know Satan that's his
primary objective his primary objective
is to get human beings to turn away from
their creator and their sustainer and
instead worship other than him so in
reality those who are setting up
partners with God are worshipping Satan
yeah and to look at the fundamental
message and make it easy for Owen when
you look at the authenticity of the
Quran as opposed to the Bible you look
at that because you don't have a copy as
great scholars of the Bible one for
instance Barr Arum he I quote him he
says we don't have a copy of a copy of a
copy of a copy of a copy of any original
text yeah
now look at the Quran evaluate that then
look at the message here of Islam which
obviously by now on you know that Islam
is peace acquired by submission to the
will of the creator and not the creation
and then look at what Christianity is
pretty much is believing of a blood
sacrifice that Jesus was God not God but
a little son of God God committed
suicide right and pretty much died Jesus
died for your sins and then the Trinity
and it becomes confusing then you got to
just have faith and so if you if you
evaluate those a simple message of pure
monotheism in Islam worship you gotta go
alone and it's not because see this is
where they go back many people and say
look it's because your good deeds know
this how you get the mercy of God right
by obeying God so then you have that
simple concept pure monotheism
worshipping God alone doing your utmost
best of obeying God loving God showing
it through your actions and then this is
how you get the mercy of God very
straightforward very simple and living
by the revelation that God Almighty sent
which is the verbatim word of God
Almighty the Quran and the example of
Prophet Muhammad if you were living
during time with Jesus you would have to
follow his Sunnah his way his example
Muhammad peace and buzzy-bee Onam is
just a final messenger so you have this
over here and then you have over here
this crust of Christianity the salvation
blood of Christ three and one Trinity
and this is from there if you which one
d-does your innate nature draw two more
right and then a severe be sincere in
that right that's why a lot of
Christians end up believing Christianity
is because I just they don't it doesn't
make sense to them they don't understand
it and then they think that all
religions are equally nonsensical and in
their Creed in their theology and so
they become atheists when they could be
Muslims they if they had only reflected
now Satan shake down got him in another
trap another trick another trick yeah
and atheists themselves they're also
committing shirk because they're
worshipping the self they're worshipping
the self they're worshiping their reason
thinking that the reason knows all and
can understand all
and can evaluate they also they've done
surveys about the number of atheists who
are superstitious and they actually
believe in karma and spirit stones and
spiritual energy it's a very 30 percent
of atheists actually have these kinds of
or reincarnation yeah atheists who
believe in this kind of stuff shirk is
the only religion that does not have
idol worship is Islam
the only monotheistic faith is Islam
yeah all these other religions and non
religions atheism is a type of religion
you can find you'll find that kind of
taking the authority from God and
ascribing others as God I like what you
said there we're almost out of time but
just covering these points so we can
make it easy for Owen and others so they
don't have to do too much legwork we
give them the the crust of the message
cliff no it's lift notes
yeah the Atheist that's really powerful
because they will they will subside to
doing a bunch of rituals superstitions I
heard this great example of you know the
the god of fortune Fortuna have you
heard of this one you know souls can may
be in God where where they would they
would attribute this to good luck bad
luck my fortune year fortune because
when you ask the age it's all based on
good luck bad luck right they would
actually you know the things that they
do for instance knocking on wood this is
that old skin and even God they will
knock on wood knock on this tree got to
go and wake it up and to go ahead and to
make prayers to it so if you look at
these things that they do my lucky shirt
lucky rabbit's foot
you know the knocking on the wood all
these are pagan rituals that go back to
somehow connected to some pagan yeah you
see so much of that the thing about
atheism is all they do is borrow alright
they borrow from other religions but
they want to claim that they're not
religious and one really prominent
atheist John Gray made this statement
and he's written an entire book on it
the seven types of atheism and his claim
is that all of the values that atheism
profess in this modern period are
actually borrowed from Christianity so
they have
in those values like be nice to your
neighbors tolerate people who are
different from you these are all values
taken from Christianity and other
religions and then you're living by that
and you're claiming to be an ethical
person but without religion so you're
just not giving credit to your sources
so this is the reality of atheism as
recognized by atheists themselves so
Owen Benjamin that's his name yeah Owen
Benjamin I hope you've enjoyed this and
all his followers and the Joe Rogan's
and everybody we got much love for you
that's a word we're sharing this message
and hopefully you can follow with louder
and crowd on them they can follow some
of the lead that he's been taking now
and opening his mind and and putting
things in context and not speaking out
of line he's in the video showing that
hold on I'm not an expert here on the
make let me bring on an expert and he
said some good things but if as a
Christian he can profess I believe this
is in the Gospel of John of something
that we would say this is pretty
accurate where Jesus is had said that
this is life eternal that they may know
you the only true God and Jesus whom you
have sent so if you can shift that from
taking Jesus as a literal son of God or
a God to one that God Almighty sent out
of his love for guidance because he was
the way the truth and the light you
couldn't bypass him to get to God you
had to obey Him as a messenger of God
and he was particular time period and
people now if you can shift it and then
look at like you mentioned the the
Prophet to come after Jesus was Prophet
Muhammad it's also their prophet in the
bat Mohammed in the bow to investigate
this but I like to leave people with
that homework to earnestly seek the
guidance from your Creator ask the
crater for guidance and start to do be
courageous and brave like you're showing
to be now and do this legwork and now
you make that shift that there's only
there's nothing first the negation
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens and earth in
Arabic Allah and Mohammed now is the
messenger because he is for all time
until the end of time and that'll be
that simple step and he would be
entering into the mercy of God and that
promise at the end if he dies on that of
Jenna paradise forever ever
is that right absolutely yeah so any
message for Owen I can't say it better
than that
and then he can check you out also at
the and others can check you out at a
Muslim skeptic yeah Muslim skeptic calm
and then Alesana Institute Alice nah
it's coming from the statement of
Walmart that's not and how are we not on
the truth and this is a statement from
all more the the Khalifa and the great
companion of the Prophet peace be upon
him and so I started an institute with
this idea of are we not on the truth
isn't Islam the truth and we have to
have that confidence in Islam as the
truth in order to spread it in order to
raise our kids so that's the Institute I
teach things like why is Aslam the truth
a lot of Muslims are confused about this
question for whatever reason evidence is
a rational argumentation if you believe
in God
right because that's the biggest
demographic people who believe in God
but their spiritual they don't know why
should I follow a specific religion but
this class that I teach is dedicated to
why is Islam the truth to give you that
boost and confidence and understanding
of why Islam is head and shoulders above
all of these man-made ideologies and
Islam is god-given it's not man-made so
so that's oh you can find me on online
Muslim skeptic calm and all that's not
institute is you can also do a google
search and find it intro thank you
brother thank you for being with us here
on the Deen show
allah the creator of heavens and earth
reward you just look like salami yeah
and Owen I want you to imagine a house a
beautiful beautiful mansion of any sort
that you can paint your mind and your
admiring it and there's just one brick
there that's missing from this beautiful
house the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him he described
himself as that mist that brick that was
missing he was the completion the
finality of the messengership now if
you're sincere and you're genuine and
you look into us you'll come to that
realization that he was indeed the
messenger sent to you and to all of
mankind as a mercy to the world Prophet
Muhammad and as you said peace be upon
him and peace be upon Jesus and all the
other message
they were sent with the same simple
message worship the Creator not the
creation the one God will see you next
guy time guys subscribe if you haven't
already hit the notification bell leave
us your takeaways in the comments below
until next time in the greetings of
Jesus Mohammed and all the messengers
peace be with you
assalamu alaikum